algunos de ellos tienen familiares acá
en Washington y en Estados Unidos y
obviamente viajarán a respectivas
ciudades para hacer acogidos por estas
personas tratar de acoplarse a
Washington y Estados Unidos en general
el gobierno estadounidense les prometió
un estatus legal bajo respaldo
humanitario por los próximos dos años
esto quiere decir que tendrán permiso no
solamente de vivir sino de trabajar
también en Estados Unidos sin embargo
para las personas que no tienen
familiares Pues el departamento de
estado va a lograr a tratar trabajar
también con Adidas nicaragüense para
tratar de acomodarlos en casas en
lugares en comunidades de nicaragüenses
que quieran acoger los que quieran
ayudar a estas personas y inicialmente
las personas que no tengan como quedarse
o donde quedarse inicialmente acá en
Estados Unidos para poder quedarse en
este hotel que están en el que llegaron
cerca de ocho semanas mientras se
encuentran donde hospedarse bueno Y como
ya lo habíamos dicho el presidente
Ortega se expresó negando que esto fuera
a cambio de un levantamiento de las
sanciones que ha sido una de las
hipótesis al respecto Cuál ha sido la
postura de Estados Unidos frente a esto
y frente a la táctica del gobierno
nicaragüense de encarcelar a sus
opositores
hace unos horas el portavoz del
departamento de estado dijo que este era
un acercamiento que esperara que
esperaba que esto sirviera para abrir un
diálogo pues mucho más cercano con el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega y el mensaje
muy parecido dio Anthony hoy diciendo
que esta era una apertura de puertas
precisamente para ese diálogo sin
embargo las sanciones continúan esto no
quiere decir que la liberación de estos
prisioneros ahora desterrados de su país
quiera decir que Estados Unidos
considera levantar las sanciones que
tiene frente al régimen de Daniel Ortega
así que por ahora estas relaciones
bilaterales seguirán a pesar de lo
ocurrido